hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield season 3
predictions you overall I feel like
season 2 finished on a much stronger
note than season 1 and there's just some
really clear things that they can follow
up on there gonna be a lot of fun you
know mostly the Inhumans for those of
you that are wondering when it's coming
back season 3 will premiere about the
same time season 2 premiered that's at
the end of September international
people I'm not exactly sure what it's
premiering again in the UK probably the
same time it premiered last year just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
season two yet so here we go top five
predictions number five Simmons will be
back I know a lot of you were wondering
whether or not that was the Venom
symbiote like she's gonna come out with
some sort of crazy symbiote that's not
the case I don't think there's gonna be
any spider-man crossover with agents of
shield any spider-man related stuff is
gonna be kept to the movies although you
know we might see some jokes about
spider-man jokes and subtle references
are usually okay to do regardless of
which character you're talking about as
long as you don't mention the actual
name that is how you conjure lawsuits
wouldn't it be awesome if there was an
inhuman that did that they just conjured
lawsuits that's how we're gonna take
down Hydra this year we're just gonna
conjure a bunch of lawsuits and bring
them down with crushing debt as much as
they don't get to do movie stuff on the
TV show the good thing is is they they
kind of have free reign with a lot of
the Kree mythology and that Creoles will
probably the back door to that the
actress that plays Simmons said that she
feels like that thing just transported
her somewhere like it took her to some
sort of interdimensional prison it makes
sense that if you unleash that on a much
Inhumans it sucked them up it would
probably I'll take them somewhere to be
held and I know you're all asking does
that mean that Simmons is an inhuman
probably it only activates in the
presence of Inhumans they made that
pretty clear earlier in the episode
whatever Gordon busted in and it started
going all liquid after that Mack rushed
in and it stayed perfectly solid so
clearly Mack not an inhuman even though
he's capable of being co-opted by Kree
technology they turned him into that
giant golem in the first half of the
season they do have to nail down the way
they're gonna treat the mythology just a
little bit more the way I think about
what happened to Mack is the first half
of the season he was co-opted the same
way Loki's scepter like the of the mind
gem co-opted Hawkeye in the first
Avengers movie but just to be clear at
the mind gem and inhuman Creek nology
two completely different things onto
number four the fish oil terrigen bomb
will give rise to new Inhumans
characters original to
show the producer said that they went
the fish-oil route rather than full-on
terrigen bomb just to avoid some
unnecessary complications if they were
to do an actual bomb it would be a much
more public thing and they're probably
not gonna do that until the Inhumans
movies so they don't want to step on a
lot of the movie toes that they're not
ready to do yet but they do want new
powered people popping up everywhere in
case I didn't make that clear you're
actually you're inhuman whether you have
powers or not going through the mist
doesn't make you an inhuman it just
reveals your true self agent you know
unlock your potential sometimes there's
a little confusion about that so I'll
understand if you guys want to call the
power people Inhumans and any other
people just regular people but Coulson
is a really good example of someone who
could survive Kree blood but could not
hold the obelisk just you know just
because his hands started to change that
was actually one of the big questions
you know what would happen if Coulson
were to go through the Terrigen mists is
he an inhuman the answer we know now is
no I actually think that's a good thing
because his character is already really
weird and he's supposed to be the person
that reacts to all the crazy stuff the
big powered people that will start the
season with will be Lincoln in Skye
they'll be the basis for that new
caterpillar team they don't have
Gordon's teleporting ability anymore so
it'll take them longer to track down
people but they have those new quinjets
that Fitz is working on the good thing
about finding more powered people is is
that it forces them to raise the level
of the villains up so heroes get
stronger villains also get stronger
meaning that the action will probably be
that much crazier next year so if you
really like you know super-powered
action we're gonna get lots more of that
on to number three
bigger civil war movie crossover one of
the big complaints of the season is is
that the age of Ultron crossover seemed
like a very last-minute thing even
though they knew about it going into
season two like before season two ever
started the producers knew what was
gonna be happening one of the big
reasons I think that they've toned down
that crossover is just because of the
nature of what was going on in age of
Ultron
they weren't supposed to have shield it
was all about stark privatizing world
peace shield was still in shambles and
they had all this stuff going on with
Hydra next year that won't be the case
shield is back there finding powered
people
they'll be capable of helping out in a
bigger way so hopefully we will see a
couple Power people in the movie and
that will serve as the basis for a
shield crossover like hey we have some
powered people here
Coulson's been dealing with this but as
for the Avengers finding out that
Coulson is still alive that still kind
of opened the air the
those are making civil war joss whedon
was the one that said that he didn't
like the Coulson was still alive even
though he is the one that got agents of
shield off the ground in the first place
so just because Joss Whedon didn't like
a certain plot point doesn't mean that
the Russos won't use it
Whedon also kind of complained a little
bit about Bucky coming back the Russos
brought Bucky back for winter soldiers
so you could argue that the Russos are
really good at resurrecting dead
characters on to number two Ward will be
the big bad of the season there was a
big shift in agents of shield season 2
where you had Hydra being the big bad
for the first half of the season then
the second half it was all about this
Inhumans conflict
they might do the same thing you know
where it's this one arc the first half
of the season the second half it focuses
on something else but Ward is building a
team he will be the big bad for the
first half of the season at least that
was what killing agent 33 was all about
you know and him in the bar afterwards
he was kind of on the fence before it
seemed like he genuinely liked her but
in killing her he also kind of killed
some of the good that was still left
inside of him you could argue that he
was faking it the whole time it was kind
of hard to tell from the actors
performance I think he could have loved
her but in killing her he definitely
jumped off the deep end and there is no
going back with Skye like that that is
done the funny thing is is that at Comic
Con last year the actors were still
shipping skyward clearly that's not the
direction the showrunners wanted to go
and I think that's totally fine season 2
was more about family relationships than
anything else you can also make the
argument that Ward you know being
classic team shield is kind of like up
this dysfunctional family so then
fighting each other is kind of like
another family relationship really
really dysfunctional family relationship
that's usually where things get fun you
know when heroes turn on themselves
that's kind of what's going on in civil
war so you could argue that the show is
moving fairly closely to the narrative
of Civil War although in the context of
agents of shield it's you know a little
bit more good and evil and that's not
really the case in civil war in the
movie and finally my number one
prediction ABC and Marvel will try to
spin off another new show from season 3
if you remember there was the failed
Bobby hunter spin-off they said there's
still a chance that could happen I don't
think they chose to pass on that because
they picked up agent Carter like they
had agent Carter it was kind of up in
the air as to whether or not was coming
back and they had this other spin-off I
just feel like they looked at the agents
of shield spin-off and just felt like
the premise wasn't strong enough
or wasn't a direction that they wanted
to double down on thanks to shows like
the flash finding great success with
crazy comic book superpowers I think
that they're going more in that
direction they're gonna double down on
Inhumans so any other spin-off so they
do will involve more powered people or
more notable comic book characters they
are developing a new show based on a
pre-existing character they're like
they're trying to reimagine a comic book
character they didn't say which one but
it's ABC and Marvel so I feel like it's
a female character John really pitched a
cloak-and-dagger series but ABC kind of
passed on that he came back with a
really big interest in integrating
Kamala Khan which is the Miss Marvel
right now in the comics that doesn't
mean that it'll go but I do think that
they're trying to move towards a Miss
Marvel TV series eventually just because
they're gonna do Captain Marvel in the
movies so it makes sense that they would
try to take advantage of the character
on TV but it remains to be seen when
that could air one of the big issues
with a Miss Marvel TV series is is that
she is like a Captain Marvel fan girl
and she takes the name after she goes
through the Terrigen mists you know how
does she become Miss Marvel if there's
no Captain Marvel yet the back door to
that is Civil War if they tease Carol
Danvers in a certain way they can move
closer to Captain Marvel and I'd say
like debut a Miss Marvel TV series in
2017 there's so many unanswered
questions about that but right now the
best evidence points to a Miss Marvel TV
series based on the Kamala Khan
character here's my big question for you
guys
you know if ABC and Marvel are gonna do
a spin-off series based on a female
character with powers who would you want
to see them do consider it would
probably be a character that would stay
on TV like it wouldn't just go in all
the movies all of a sudden they've had a
lot of success with the movie crossovers
but I think the TV shows try to do
everything they can to stand on their
own because we're like ramping up into
Captain America Civil War now - I'm
gonna start doing some more Civil War
ant-man videos so be sure to subscribe
to get everything if there's any bonus
videos you guys really want me to do
just check my like Avengers playlist and
see if there's anything I haven't
already done feel free to make any
requests I think the real mission right
now should be to get Punisher back on TV
like in the Netflix series someway maybe
after defenders they already have a
bunch of characters are trying to work
on right now like Luke Cage Jessica
Jones iron fist Punisher
would fit perfectly in that very graphic
very bloody universe and yes by all
accounts defenders will
crossover with Avengers infinity war
other really big reminder flash finale
tonight there will be crazy time travel
so be sure to watch it I'll post the
video after the episode airs but well
you guys wait for that you can click
here for all my aces and shield videos I
just did like a top 5 spin-off show
video and you can click here for all my
Avengers videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you